It was on a baseball diamond that Dugan Smith first knew something was wrong with his leg.
After sliding in the base, his right knee felt unusually stiff and sore.
But that night I looked at his knee and he had three little bumps on his knee, that...
...we could actually move around and we're like, "What is that?"
It turned out to be a malignant tumor, the size of a softball on Dugan's thigh bone.
After undergoing chemotherapy to kill the cancer,...
...Dugan then underwent a rare and remarkable procedure.
Basically, we take out the entire middle part of the leg...
...and then we take the bottom part of the leg and leave the nerves connected.
We reconnect the blood vessels and we turn the leg around backwards.
It's called the Van Nes Rotationplasty procedure...
...performed by Dr. Joel Mayerson of Ohio State's James Cancer Hospital.
He says by turning Dugan's leg around backwards,...
...his calf muscle is now acting as his thigh...
...and his ankle has become his knee.
And because his bone is alive and well as Dugan grows, his leg does too.
Today with the help of a prosthesis, Dugan is not only walking again,...
...he's playing basketball and his favorite sport baseball,...
...much to the delight of his father and coach.
He's a very upbeat positive kid. He's always been that way. He's always been very competitive,...
...so I knew those things would help him.
Those qualities have helped not only in getting him back in the game,...
...but learning what winning is truly all about.
People can see that,...
...just because a you have a prosthetic leg doesn't mean you can't do it.
So, I just like to show people that I can do anything that I want to do.
At Ohio State's James Cancer Hospital, this is Clark Powell reporting.